c'est ici que je suis arrivé à l'âge de
9 ans en novembre fin novembre 1980 donc
c'était un record roissy charles gaulle
je me souviens son moment de
l'atterrissage où les pistes étaient
recouvert de neige je n'avais jamais vu
avant les flocons c'était très beau ça
marque encore aujourd'hui je pensais que
j'étais peut-être au paradis c'est pas
avoir vécu l'enfer
on était venu les années 80 pour fuir
les génocide cambodgien qui a dessiné un
peu près un tiers de la population donc
si tu es vraiment pour notre survie et
pour notre billet pour se reconstruire
qu'on est venu donc on a rejoint mais
mes grands parents dans un premier temps
dans cette tour
quand je suis arrivé la hauteur de
lui-même impressionné puisqu'il y avait
rien de tel au cambodge ont amusé à
remonter les 28e étage et redescendre à
pied à l'époque l'appartement qu'on voit
derrière c'est l'appartement dans lequel
on a vécu donc
notre premier appartement en france en
famille on était donc on avait une
petite chambre ont logé à 4 sur sur des
lits superposés
cette première appartement s'éviter le
l'endroit où on se sentait vraiment
famille en sécurité qu'on n'était pas ce
train
on nous demandait
dans les camps
on pouvait
là on mangeait un médecin à notre rythme
on va aller à l'école
la rue pajol c'est comme une première
école où j'étais scolarisé en france
je crois que j'avais peut-être deux
années de retard sur la sq a été non
jamais assez aller à l'école sauf les
premiers jours où je pensais qu'on me
séparer à nouveau de mes parents donc
c'était vraiment difficile cette
séparation et les premiers jours ici ont
été difficiles non pas à cause des profs
qui ont été je pense très patient et
très très compréhensif mais à cause du
regard des autres
d autres personnes on se comprenait pas
y penser que sont le jeu moquer d'eux
réciproquement ya élevé sur une case 25
peut-être en asiatiques qui je peux vais
à peu près correspondre c'est là
également que
j'ai eu
des soutiens en force et en français
avec une propre extraordinaire qui
s'appelait aligne revers de la médaille
c'est que je en apprenant le français
gilles binet aussi ma langue natale
voilà on est dans une des tours du xiiie
où j'ai vécu
avec mes parents lorsque je suis arrivé
au collège
l'âge de 13-14 ans 13e étage et c'est là
où j'ai découvert que contrairement à
l'est
col de mantet rouge était dans le xviiie
qui avait aussi d'autres personnes
origine sit in au maire
donc qu'ils avaient
la même histoire que moi
coût
membre de leur famille vécu
le génocide cambodgien là on est d'al
des olympiades où j'ai également pas mal
de souvenirs parce que j'avais cours à
la faculté de droit paris 1 sorbonne qui
est juste à la fin de la dalle dg j'ai
choisi d'étudier le droit je pense que
c'était inconscient déjà dès le premier
jour j'ai posé les pieds en france et
même avant parce que mes parents m'ont
dit que la france est en chinois ça veut
dire parcours effarant chinois c'est le
droit et puis je pense que c'était
également pour remercier et comprendre
comprendre un peu
quelques quelque part mon histoire
rapport au statut spécifique étude des
réfugiés que les jeux que je comprends
aujourd'hui mais que je connais pas à
l'époque lorsque je suis arrivé en
france cette générosité et cabella
france